yeah okay we carry feet sipping empathy
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free
this is tea we carry V Michael makeup
good morning everybody
for 20 I know that's got a lot of you
fired up super excited about today sorry
I'm just posting something on the gram
good morning good morning good morning
April 20th I hope everybody's doing well
I know we're in it the beards are
growing out the excitement is building
the anxiety is building we are now well
into this global pandemic and I hope
everybody's families are healthy and I
hope you're starting to turn some of the
angst and curiosities and concerns into
optimism practicality hope humility I
think the show has been unbelievable and
I've been very grateful for everybody
who's been tuning in so as a matter of
fact on that note if you could just take
a screenshot right now of either of the
screen you're watching on a laptop or a
screen shot there and tweet it out
Facebook it out or putting your
Instagram story with the link to this
episode right now I'd like to bring in
some new folks some new friends into the
realm let me say good morning some
people in the comments
Sagi Karma what's good Rosa hores Pettis
how are you Mike man what's good but he
usually Higgins yacht Chuck great to see
you then Dane back sir
papi TV Saeed Jabbar what's good my man
it's great to see you always great to
see man I move for you heavy hockey
wraps Jeff Gargas Linda jr. Mary
Robinson Tanya and Travis Rogers thank
you all so much for being here really
really really appreciate it
Andrea Erica guarde Garrett Glen Ashley
Gomez Chris Gareth flight Winfield good
morning good morning Cindy I'll lizanne
this fun all right let's get this showed
us just dust
get in here real quick Dustin not Justin
[Music]
what's up is I think you're becoming a
viral hit I'm sure you are you start to
get some buzz doesn't or you like
feeling it are you getting like some
dm's like give me a little like shoot
shoot with me like I'm your friend like
talk to me are you getting a little buzz
you getting a little action on social
some DM some love yeah I mean I mean
definitely but it's I mean mostly just
people that want to be on the show wait
okay they're right hooking all day oh
don't throw up I'm good I'm good what's
cooking lots of gratitude for being here
happy to have you so I had a like write
out my questions because I can't even
form it um I always watch her content to
find the answer I feel like I still
can't get the full clarity so right
we're here for here's the backstory so I
I'm an actor comedian I do stand-up I
post on tik-tok I post on Instagram I
post on YouTube everything is
incrementally progressing okay great I
can hear your voice being like just be
patient just like [ __ ] like like [ __ ]
like just like be patient okay process I
hear it okay we're going in a positive
direction great but sometimes I feel
lost like I'll watch Tripel do stand-up
and I'm like if I only did stand-up
I would kill it and then I'm like if I
only did tick-tock I'd have 10 million
followers
hmm and so I know I've heard you say
before that doing things in waves is
okay like it's okay to go hard with
content and then it's okay to go hard
with stand-up and shut everything off
that's tough for me doing stuff in waves
okay I don't know if I should shut
something off and then I'm constantly
trying to find the intertwine like I
know you have a pillar content so I
could film everything and then divide it
out it's just
and so every morning I'm like what's the
most important thing I can get done
today and sometimes I'm like and then I
get hit with an audition and then I'll
shut everything off language phones off
everything and I'll go away for like
three days memorize the lines so and
then I want to start a product drag it
now so it's good all right let's break
it down let me ask you an interesting
question what you kept and it could
change and I'm sure it has changed as
your careers evolved but right now what
is the ultimate long-term goal is and I
don't know if it's gonna become extinct
but movies TV show like I want to be
known as the greatest character actress
like wow she's like our generations
Meryl Streep she can transform into
characters she can tell stories so I
know that's my responsibility to put you
know 20 I'm gonna I'm gonna throw some
curveballs at you because I think what
you're giving me is enough context to
know that you know a lot of my answers
so what I'm trying to think about is
back to the point of why I think this
show is working is have more time to go
deeper or more contextual so a couple
things how much time or energy you spend
on a management or ages um all day every
day I mean it means finding
representation or working with them both
yeah it's a lot of every day and I can
have an Excel spreadsheet of like
producers I want to work with and like
you know I'm working what about
management and agents do you have one
yeah and you know it and like I not to
put him on blast like one of the things
that's been very obvious to me is is the
serendipity of the relationship graph so
if your goal is to be Meryl Streep or or
or have a real true acting career right
yes I do believe a singular tik-tok I
mean looking look at King Bhoj right
he's like yeah holy moly
right absolutely he's been able to do it
he came from vine and here he is I turn
on Netflix and he's in the movies right
like the couple things where do you live
LA
in New York right now but LA go back and
forth got it so one thing I would spend
a ton of time on is content strategy on
tick tock around the children of the
power agents in Hollywood okay so tell
stories that nope I'm going very narrow
for you I would find out who the 50
biggest agents in Hollywood are which is
crazy okay and I would literally try to
find out if their sons and daughters are
on social media like I'm talking [ __ ]
like Kojak Sherlock Holmes it okay and
would literally tag them in my content
tag they're kids
yep Gary B is telling you to tag the
exactions bits and let's write TV
executives yep and be like wanting to do
it tick tock do it nope tagging you know
how that works they're just gonna see it
okay dad no I don't do that now it's
really interesting I know it seems like
you know again like really listening to
this call and you know a lot of things I
believe that do I believe a single viral
epic tick tock can get you there I do do
do I think that that takes a lot of
output and a lot of serendipity and a
lot of things like I'll give you a good
example I always felt like special media
was a good place for me to create top of
the funnel brand right I spent eight
years saying no to everything and then
plenty of the apps came apples first
original show Gweneth Paltrow will I am
just gob or the other judges it's a good
elevation for me in my domain expertise
of making investments in apps
yeah it's Apple first show
I'm completely I'd finally make the jump
I commit to that time and then they
decide to not do what they just did
which is what I thought they were gonna
do they decided to distribute it through
Apple music and four and a half people
saw it if it's not thank you it if if
that got distributed to Netflix or or
Apple TV's new version or even Amazon
Prime or human
that would have worked for you so I have
tons of strategy yeah
gave all this thoughts there's so much
serendipity that goes into that game
right but then we control our tick-tock
instagraming so a couple things that I
actually think there's two parallel
paths the two opposites you go super
high and you try to truly penetrate the
awareness graph of the 50 gals and guys
who run Hollywood from the agent side
right and then you do what you're doing
what you do well is creative at scale
across all the relevant platforms mm-hmm
because those are actually the two ways
people get to become who you want to
become
right I'm like pulled in a traditional
and a social world but yeah and and mark
so loud ski saying like this the first
time I don't like what Gary says and I
totally get it like I understand that a
lot of people like what that seems awful
creepy or wrong but here's my point of
view my point of view very simply is
people are on these platforms for
content you're trying to bring awareness
to somebody you can DM them you can send
them a nice link email on LinkedIn you
can send a letter you can another gift
basket
I genuinely believe that tagging you
know people that are influencers of the
influencer whether that's admins whether
that's best friends whether that's
children I don't I don't if you're
making a age-appropriate video and
everyone's like oh a three-year-old 14
Rhodes [ __ ] hear more [ __ ] in the
pool then every single adult I know
everyday people living in a naive world
and so I I'm empathetic and understand
people's point of view on that but I'm
completely convinced that building
awareness towards children as you know
or or influencers or admins leads to
opportunity yeah yeah I'm never somebody
who's scared to reach out cold and you
know I have producers that follow me on
Instagram I feel a lot of pressure every
time I post I got big people following
me big execs I mean like I can't name
names but top dogs like so I feel a lot
of pressure and then I know I need to
get my quality up I know you talked to
people about not
think about quality but if I see myself
as an actress it does need to be
top-notch sound once in a while not
every video listen I'm with you I'm
genuinely not against it
I'm against it when people can't afford
it or use it as an excuse not to make
yeah but I think I need to kick my game
up and I think there is the occasional
iPhone video great um I I think that I
think that real talent evaluators are
able to see through production value and
I argue that the best talent evaluators
in Hollywood often need the ability to
be able to dream it versus seeing it so
let me give you an example this Thursday
is the NFL Draft a lot of kids are gonna
get drafted who actually play in small
schools because the GM's dream that if
they played in big school they would
have been even better because they would
have better weight rooms better coaches
so I actually feel like a lot of the
Hollywood types actually overlook and
skip over people with my production on
YouTube and tik-tok because it shows
them exactly who they are and they just
miss it because it's still a grade below
Hollywood but when they see it an iPhone
or kind of like whatever they dream like
ooh I see that star I can polish that
story it's ego totally people want to
discover me I mean I have so many people
but stick with me here of course that
but like stick with me because I don't
want you to lose this point the reason
lower quality content has value is they
dream up oh if I put production value
behind her she can crush somebody keep
in mind I see about it I got it
and then doing stuff in waves just like
[ __ ] it if you have to do stand-up for
two weeks look now I think people need
to do what comes natural to them because
I think they need a lot of output and
hard work to actually get there so to me
you know if waves work great if you need
to go hardcore and something for six
months grade if you do helter-skelter
every day great like I think that's I'm
I want to give a lot of different
scenarios to people so they can find
their way got it awesome now give a
shout out to your account so people can
follow yourself everything is Natalie
Friedman on Instagram tick-tock
Friedman is felt like fried man I love
it
good luck back thank you so much
appreciate you bye all right shout out
to everybody here by the way just do
somebody say something about the IRS I
didn't carry what can I get the IRS gets
their people's money ASA got it
well people be getting their money
because the amount of stuff being bought
on e-commerce last week is ludicrous as
as stimulus checks have hit and I'm so
[ __ ] angry
[ __ ] man like literally people get their
$1200 check or more and they [ __ ]
spend it immediately [ __ ] it's almost
like we like I just all my ecommerce
friends are like we're exploding this
week and I'm like what the [ __ ]
literally hundreds of them and I'm like
holy [ __ ] people are actually taking the
stimulus check and buying dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway Dustin keep going hey how's
it going Gary do you go by Bill or
William Williams great man so just a
little background on me I'm an actor as
well a probably best known for playing
the Red Power Ranger on TV and I
actually took a lot away from the
conversation you just had I love writing
down notes like crazy what most hit you
William the thing you said at the end
about you need to do what comes natural
to you because there's so much output
necessary to achieve anything struck
right yeah it completely struck people
create friction oh I needed you were
like Gary or any do do like William they
create friction
you know like I'd love to be Sam darn
'old there's no throwing footballs
outside that are gonna get me there you
know like you know like people create
friction and I'm trying to create you
know like just a stream of of pass
throughs because the output is the
variable just yeah just completely
following through like I think about
that where there's there's not really
any rules where people will say that
they'll follow one person's content or
this person's content and they'll use a
certain approach but basically my
question for you was so earlier on life
was very simple for me I was like
this economic student who dropped out to
pursue acting and I got maniacal about
acting and I did a whole lot in one year
but then like I felt this thing inside
where I was like this isn't moving fast
enough for me there's so much more I can
do I have time on my hands I've got
potential so I started an online fitness
coaching business I wrote two books and
I just started building other things
built my youtube built a podcast when I
got into your content I was like ooh
time to get on every platform so I built
up this podcast I started you know doing
the pillar content strategy where I
would put a lot out and I got myself to
a point now where I've always liked
biting off more than I can chew but I've
got myself to a point now where it's
like there are so many plates spinning
every day do you have the humility to
shut things down and have perceived
losses hmm I don't feel like like I'm
gonna point yet where I need to shut it
down I just don't know how to prioritize
all of it yet that's an excuse okay what
I mean by that is prioritization comes
in the thing that needs it the most it's
like children if you have four children
you need to prioritize the child that's
most struggling at that moment yeah yeah
art is Asians easy humility to shut
something down this hard then I probably
like the humility it makes sense notice
how I go to something that's not so
obvious but is the [ __ ] answer mm-hmm
humility humility to say you know people
people with a lot of ambition and energy
whether they are Gabor's like me and
just talk [ __ ] like I'm gonna [ __ ]
everything is gonna be humungous or if
they're quiet but they still have 5 to 7
people that they value very much knowing
what they're up to
mm-hmm almost everybody right now is
doing things that they don't want to be
doing because they don't have the
humility to take the micro loss mm-hmm
okay
I can think of a few things like that of
course you like immediately right like
this the humans work like immediately
I'm talk
like yeah I'm [ __ ] the podcast like it's
taking too much time you know what I
mean
yeah I do it all pro I do it all the
time I have so many I'm working on
action figures right now I've been
trying to launch a beanie brand for like
four years like like you know like I
take the losses Micro lose all the time
just constantly but most people don't
have the humility and I think humility
has to be one of the great emerging if
we do not if my audience let me just go
actually very simple if my audience
doesn't quadruple down on humility post
covet it would be a real missed
opportunity because I'm very passionate
about it I communicate it I articulated
here we are where we you know for you
brother and and William and a lot of
other people watching right now
literally I genuinely believe in the
next you know week people like a hundred
people right now just decided to drop
something that's gonna completely open
them up people are talking about
prioritizing because they don't have the
humility to drop three things they
already know they just need the
encouragement and the courage and the
shield they need this video to point to
to be like well Gary Vee said and by the
way my great love of my life is being
the shield that allows people to do
things that make them happy I want
people to point to me I want kids to
point their parents to me I want parents
to point their kids to me I want
somebody who you know stops doing their
podcast and their mom makes a snarky
comment city see you always [ __ ] fail
to show this video and say [ __ ] you mom
you know what I mean like I want that
well part of the mindset for me behind
it is like it and this comes from like
the past was like weight training and
sports and stuff like that is that I
know what that pressure does to me like
it
yeah I like it and I feel like having
that weight on my shoulders sometimes
let me so I do too let me tell you the
difference between you and I I don't
have this question mm-hmm that's right
well this yeah what I mean by that
though is I want you to figure out if
you've made the ideology
within yourself that you've created an
ideology that you like it or do you
actually like it it's a very important
point brother because you know because
if you're asking it if you're sitting on
it you may not like it as much as you
think I like it but I don't want to drop
the ball on anything that's that's the
way that I feel I feel like I I need to
follow through have to if you're a
juggler you drop balls mm-hmm okay
that makes sense I'm telling you right
now it's [ __ ] humility I love
spinning 49 plates and watching 13 crash
because it keeps me in a learning
mindset and I don't give a [ __ ] if the
people who watching me spend the plate
laugh at me when I dropped a plate
because I look at them and ask him don't
worry about my plates how many plates
are you [ __ ] spinning yeah yeah okay
that makes sense to me that makes sense
to me you know what I mean yeah yeah
it's humility I'm telling you do you do
you ever drop the the plate on so many
things and then you just keep piling
more plates on and you maybe I should
just focus on the plates that I have
spinning always yeah I hope you're not
doing Wehling on the plate that broke it
[ __ ] broke no I know I honestly don't
do well like I don't dwell at all I
totally hear you on that
I just feel an obligation to the people
that I work with and a lot of different
things too to pull through for them and
I wanna go through for them in different
ways like if you have to drop that thing
you can hire two of them on the thing
that's working or help them get another
like we're gonna have to go through
layoffs I'm helping people get other
jobs mm-hmm okay I guess you yes what I
mean you could you could you don't have
to keep them paid on that plate you can
go help them be in the fork business or
they can come and help you spin the
plate that's actually [ __ ] working
yeah I got you
so just reallocate move things around
and keep moving forward again and a lot
of times the person that you're letting
down you actually deep down know that
they're not good enough and don't do
what I did for a long time which is
carry them out of compassion you know
what you want to do is set them up with
candor and give them another opportunity
somewhere else that was a real
shortcoming of mine I carry dead weight
for years decades
because I'm a nice person but ultimately
I created a resent relationship with
that individual and they weren't growing
with me so I've learned only recently in
the last half decade that it is okay to
let people go especially if you're
willing to help them post you yeah okay
I got you hey I've got I've got one
little follow-up question real fast I'm
sure that you got people that do this
for you but do you in terms of your
whole game plan do you create like a
weekly schedule or a daily schedule or
do you do you just roll with the punches
oh I'm admin out I've three admins and
every minute I mean literally if you
look at my calendar right now every
minute of my day I'm literally booked
right now every minute no gaps until
9:00 p.m.
yeah yeah yeah I know I've literally no
idea what the [ __ ] I'm doing
Google Calendar tells me every second
it's all happening in flow with
infrastructure you got you that's how
I'm bouncing from so many things yeah
yeah okay that make sense you thought me
out of time thank you brother you got a
one take care all right that was some
good [ __ ] you know what a team let's
let's chop that up for LinkedIn let's
get that into LinkedIn let's get them
into Raghav's hands see how he wants to
position it but that felt very
operational feel like there's some
LinkedIn peeps that can get some real
value from that let's keep it going
friends a guy Gary what's up man what's
good brother I'm super happy we're happy
to be here just wanna say that first
thank you um so can I give you a little
bit of context person please all right
so I discovered you about two to three
years ago in high school I've always
loved your energy enthusiasm and passion
and your approach to everything I found
your advice super easy to apply and it
was immediate help for me in my
self-improvement journey so obviously as
you probably know like I've heard a lot
from you over the Pat past few years and
the thing that's helped me the most and
what I actually want to talk about today
is creating accessibility to where I
want to be via like the Instagram DM and
so I'm I'm a really big sports fan and
I'm super interested in like the
business side of social media so over
the summer I had DM like
a lot of accounts like on tonight
support center house of pilots bleacher
report and then you know just companies
like Nike Adidas and Puma and stuff like
individual athletes as well
and I had DM this one company called
overtime yeah and have you have you
heard of it
I've heard of everything ok so yeah I
had at the end this that was so funny
obviously I haven't heard of everything
but I'm on my [ __ ] of course I knew it
overtime is keep going ok yeah so I had
IDM this one company call it overtime I
really like the like the mission behind
it and also the creativity of their
content and you know with all these
themes like I can't remember when I
heard you say this but I had a I had
like made the decision over the summer
to DM everybody and I had like zero
expectations with any of it right I
would just you know send it and forget
about it you know fast forward four to
five months I'm literally chilling in my
my dorm I go to the University of
Minnesota by the way I'm literally just
chilling in my dorm no I like I'm about
to take a nap like my roommate James can
attest to this it's like 4:00 p.m. about
to take a nap I get this random text
message like hey it's Thomas from over
time like you want to film this
basketball game tonight and I'm like
super hesitant but I eventually you know
just saying like like [ __ ] it right and
then I just cuz I don't know the place
at all so like I was hesitant at first
but then I end up going to film this
basketball game and like long story
short it's like the best experience that
I've ever like dreamed about like I mean
I was like a big consumer of overtimes
content beforehand so like I knew like a
lot about their brand I knew what type
of videos they made I guess also I'm
like you know a super big basketball guy
so like you know the high school dynamic
and like the the you know the top
athletes that come out like that was a
super cool environment for me I loved it
and yeah so it like it was it was the
you know it was the it was the best job
ever so okay my question is like like I
I would say in the past like four to
five months I've been like super
successful and leveraging like you know
my position out over time like is truly
like a blessing to be able to work there
and I've been able to leverage it like
I've actually gotten responses you know
from zyre Wade like who's Dwyane Wade's
son and I actually like Mikey Williams
as well I don't know if you
I'm also like no no I've heard I film
something like top athletes and I've
been able to like leverage this yep
and to like get replies from other
people and I feel like Sabrina what's
the question before my audience destroys
you oh so I feel like I'm on the verge
of something and I'm just like I don't
really know what to do from there like
well what do you want to do well like
ideally like eventually I want to you
know work for like an NBA team or like
I'm like super Brenda like I'm super
into like the sports business like
industry but like and I feel like I'm on
the verge of something like the DMS and
stuff but I don't really like know what
to do from there just looking at my
conversations with Mikey Williams trying
to figure out when I first hit him up
January 2018 um you're on your way just
keep networking that's how you got here
I mean the biggest question by far is
what the [ __ ] are you doing napping at
4:00 p.m. it's just like I just came
back from like my classes at you I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm kidding I'm kidding
all right listen I think you keep doing
what you're doing as you're getting you
know connected with Mikey with you know
with Anthony with young with all these
kids that keep coming up the Israeli kid
that tall lanky kid you're in the
culture you know exactly what's
happening
keep networking keep bringing value keep
being patient try to make content for
people keep putting out karma keep your
so [ __ ] young you should not go in
for any ask or kill don't you know all
these people are trying to latch on to
brawny anxiety I like you know what's
going on they're all trying to get
something you don't get you give you
give you give you give I promise you
you'll be there because if you D I'm a
coach DM Erik Spoelstra be like you were
a film guy and you're now the coach let
me [ __ ] do film for you on on the you
know 16 year olds right now or and he'll
be like we're not interested in that but
my draft guy is what you already did you
have to do again just follow the
blueprint okay yeah that make sense also
I have like I have like a secondary
question so you talked about like
creating value and like giving giving
giving is like like something that I
need to keep doing right and so like
like where I'm at right now like what
does like giving like really look like
in terms of ask people
okay so asking is like you say mister
you've got the leverage to your point
well asking and then giving what people
want versus giving what you perceive is
the answer I just answered your question
like well what do I give I'm like easy
ask the Winston what he wants be like yo
[ __ ] with your game coach I love the way
you cook you map every see map app you
know we do map every G League head coach
and then DM them you're gonna still have
the leverage of the logo that's on your
[ __ ] chest and you're gonna say yo
what can I do for you I'm hungry all
right good talk awesome Gary thank you
gotta shake your brain it's fun that is
right
ss yep good give people want to give
what they want to give which is not
giving it's 99% of time manipulation to
set up what they actually want people
want to give me [ __ ] all the time that I
don't want because they want something
from me understand let's keep it going
juju Gary vane what's good what's up so
funny yesterday I was just presenting a
new project that we're only now on zone
call and I present what are your videos
you know to sell the product telling
people to become a digital mayor of
their hometown or look you're even
saying this you got to jump on this
product because that's exactly what our
product does and we gonna be the next
ello so stay tuned for that Gary I know
everything that's new you gonna buy
everything
we'll talk later can't wait but my
question to you is my bestie and I
Amanda I know she's watching this as I
told her just we just started our new
nonprofit organization called hope for
tomorrow we have children in our local
community in a fields of art music and
dance we want to support them and
eventually we want to have a center
where kids
come and be mentored not in just those
fields but also have lawyers they'll be
able to help them with contract you know
kids get taken advantage of all the time
in the music industry and entertainment
industry and we want to be able to be
there for them you know Gary so and I've
been going ham and I understand that she
had a pass to pass an exam but I and I
just have taken action because I'm the
type of person that if I don't take
action and I fight cool down I cool down
for real you know if I sit down to watch
a movie I'm gonna take a nap so I don't
sit down to watch movies I keep going I
gotta keep the momentum going
but you know from setting up the as a
non-profit with Facebook and everything
this stuff is hard but I understood but
one thing that I told her that I was
doing was putting the business plan
together and she said hey that's my
field now that's what I'm going to
school for I have a mentor for them you
know we can ask her for help and I said
well I kind of have a template that I'm
going by I'm kind of like to stick to
that but then I'm the type of person
that I always think a little bit more so
I started thinking like hey I got so
much on my plate maybe I should let her
handle this this is a grano thing you
know maybe she'll be better Shepherd II
has a mentor so I gave her that task
Gary has been for months I'm sorry it's
been a month for weeks and I don't have
a business plan and I've asked hey
what's going on with the business plan
do you need any help is there anything I
can do are you not comfortable with it
what's the before I understand where
you're going and and if she's watching
like look for weeks is wildly
inappropriate to deliver something in a
partnership especially when your
partner's dude you with the ears and
[ __ ] high energy like that's gonna
create friction my bigger question is
the [ __ ] do you need a business plan for
well here's the thing Gary we need a
business plan because we are going to
need people to join a country so in
order to have people do donate we need
to
able to tell them here's what we doing
this is what we plan that's all that's a
communications plan yeah that's exactly
that's it now by that sort of template
here this is this is what we need you
know you know it's on you let's say she
made the you and her made the best
[ __ ] deck of all time yeah you're
gonna present that to high net-worth
people and want them to donate yeah yeah
so that's what I'm just I'm not
critiquing I'm actually trying to
understand what you're trying to do
you're making a one more time I think
you're not making a business plan I
think you're making a presentation to
raise capital uh-huh
is that true well that's good that's
included in it you know because within
the business plan we will also have our
mission which we already have we just
have everything compacted in one you
know I understand no matter what word
you or I use I'm trying to understand
what the purpose of it is so you're
gonna present that to whom with the hope
of what well number one Gary I want to
make sure that everybody that comes into
the organization with us they know
exactly or our goals are I would have
your goal your goal is to build an
ecosystem to help the kids in your area
to not get screwed by Hollywood that you
could type that out well not just that
we and we have that and we have that but
we also first up what we are going to
have events how are we going to raise
capital for those events you know where
we will need to partner with people
people don't invest the index people
invest in people you do what if we were
to have a nonprofit and you want
everybody to be on a same page and you
want people to know here's where Gary
the foundation is gonna be within the
next five to ten years I would make
videos and post them and leave it at
that - yeah but that's not where we're
going where I'm going is somewhere a
little bit different which is people
value process and check
the box of certain things versus what
the strategy is needed to actually make
it happen
instead of making that deck I wish you
guys had made a video interviewing all
these kids on zoom' and put it out on
Facebook groups in your local community
because you would have built more
awareness for what you're actually doing
well that's our plan and that's what we
want to do with the you know with the
business plan is to have all of that so
when but that doesn't that doesn't take
depo doesn't take four [ __ ] weeks for
your friend to make a claim well my
whole question to you is how can we ask
a business partner you know or somebody
that works with you the hey I need this
whatever you come up with you know just
present it to me so we can work together
and really see where we going because we
need to have like for example the video
of the kids that's something we want to
do I'm all over social media I love
video
I love interviewing people you know
that's one of the things that we want to
do but I'm the type of person that I
wanna list make sure what we going so we
can check everything off metal is the
one ongoing takes four [ __ ] seconds
future that's what I'm saying area write
it down so I don't know I'm completely
honest we I love you with all your
energies off the charts but I mean like
I'm talking with loves right now like
right down nine things on a piece of
paper there's right wait wait she lay
like hey you know whatever you know you
it's nine things I just did it we just
did it on tea with Gary Vee she [ __ ]
you need to you're trying to do this for
kids in a local area yeah it sounds like
you need money which is ludicrous of a
strategy to start a nonprofit during
this time when nobody has money all the
money's gone although the point is not
to make money right now the boy no money
you told me you try to get out the word
out there so worship smart back it's not
about me it's never gonna be about
making money you started nonprofit
right said to me that you needed to
raise money to get this going there's no
nobody's gonna give you a check well I I
don't care I'm making my own check and
I'll put in my own money that's not then
why the [ __ ] are you spending four weeks
waiting for a deck for a presentation to
get money how do I even my point is
already talking about like Anna
like like my best friend and not her her
feelings like hey I've been waiting for
weeks you know what I'm saying like I
just want to be able to communicate that
to her without hurting her feelings like
say I love you with all my heart with
all my heart
um are you okay I love you are you okay
it shouldn't take four weeks for you to
put nine things down on a piece of paper
let's just do it right now over a Coco
your energy yeah but you're spending
time and energy to make a presentation
uh-huh to get people to give you
donations to have startup capital for
this nonprofit starting a non-profit
during a global pandemic when we lost 22
million jobs in four weeks is a real
stretch like who you going to and how
much money we had already started before
all of this we've been it's been a year
and it's a crazy story Gary because we
had a different partner we had a
president that really wasn't doing
anything and just myself and Amanda
we're doing everything and we decided
just to you know what let's just embrace
it
and let's just go in why don't why don't
you and stick me here why don't you
start why don't you start a zoom and a
Google Hangouts and just invite kids in
and just ask people to come and educate
them why don't you take the form of the
mission into a digital three platform
that can help lots of kids instead of
like having to put it in this container
of a non-profit and a center the YMCA
worked in 1972 the [ __ ] world is
different now I'm taking notes do do
people get emotional about the container
that they use or the vehicle they use to
create the mission and I keep reminding
people in business and nonprofit and
politics and everything it's not about
the vehicle don't peep romantic about
the vehicle don't make an ideology that
you're gonna have this beautiful Center
the center is there to help kids help
kids for free on the internet
make tick-tocks that help kids now I
help kids for free in my [ __ ]
underwear at two o'clock in the morning
by making content powerful yes sure sure
so check that that's right I'm glad you
picked up on that me you've put it and I
get it we're opening you know you start
to visualize something with a purpose
yeah but like [ __ ] like like like if the
purpose is to help kids this year that
you've spent with a fucked-up resident
and your best friend going through she
had to pass some tests it sounded like
and then for weeks like we're gonna
[ __ ] already impacted 8,000 kids on
[ __ ] free tic TOCs [ __ ] lives yeah
yes sure get off the romance of how
you're gonna do it and get on the
romance of what you're trying to
accomplish that shoot the vehicle
doesn't matter you know no it doesn't
and the vehicle you're trying to do
right now is expensive during a time
where that's not practical that's
actually good juju good luck take care
all right bye that ended well I'm
excited about that
who's getting in it you know what's
amazing about this show is because I
have more time I can go deeper I'm not
cutting it off you know before we get to
it that conclusion though helped you Joe
and her friend about a non-profit
because they don't need a [ __ ] build
a Center to accomplish what they want I
know there's a ton of parallels right
now to a lot of people and businesses
and parenting you know one heroes like I
just want my kid to be happy by
torturing them to be on the lacrosse
team and go to Yale what are you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like come on let's get
smarter focus on the goal not your
ideology of the vehicle to get to the
goal let's go Kevin
hey Gary how are you are you doing I'm
well I'm well thanks
that uh prior comment is a great lead-in
I got a parenting question here for you
I have a 16 year old I've got four kids
and actually have two dogs - so don't be
so you're some marking in the berries
got a 16 year old son he's my oldest he
is by all accounts you know the
traditional student does really well in
school straight A's
does greatest anodised tests you know
all that sort of stuff if this were 20
25 years ago when probably you and I
were kids we'd be saying doctor lawyer
you know born it for it yep my fear as a
parent is that he will always be a good
student and he'll be good at whatever he
does but he won't necessarily love what
he does how do you how should I help him
through that right first of all I like
I'm I don't know I don't know if that's
gonna come through I think it is
actually yep I love you I love you comin
I'd no really I mean it I just showed my
goose but look they're really coming in
like I really really love you because
your kids are very lucky to have you
that is an incredibly profound and very
like just noble question you know I
think it's about education like anything
else yeah I think just like the reverse
of like me trying to push my buddy who
like thinks his son needs to go to play
lacrosse and this and that like because
the press will get him to Yale as if
Yale means anything any like his kids
not happy I don't know it the kids the
enemy so I think I think what you want
to do is a lot of kids like that have
figured out a system they figured out
the school system and they feel safe
which is why they're gonna then take a
job that's safe but they're not gonna be
passionate or on fire so you need to
have that communication you know really
genuinely treat him like an adult and
say look this is a potential not son I
think this is exactly what's gonna
happen to you but this is a potential
thing that might happen to you and is
this where you're at like like you what
do you love or you observe them and you
pay attention to things they do
like outside of school does he show any
interests outside of school
did we lose cab Nick to me that's not
think we lost him let's get him back
let's go next woman get him back great
question
Gary what's going on brother what's good
bro a quick question quick back story I
guess been following you for about five
years since the [ __ ] Monday video stolen
on Facebook oh my god man seared into my
head but quick 30 seconds story with the
college first first-generation immigrant
back 92 for my rag family came here so
watch the entire family just work work
work work work oh I was it wasn't a
classic immigrant story where your
parents and grandparents or family
members had these kind of jobs in the
old country but here they had a [ __ ]
it was it was literally 92 they came in
my parents uncle grandparents worked in
Greece for two years got the paperwork
came to us lived in my great uncle's
home and just story Wow dude yes so a
lot of stores you know corner stores
restaurants all the way up to ownership
and whatever dad do in Iraq back in the
80s and 90s they were just working in
the restaurants they had me at 21 and
they had like 45 days to decide to join
the army or flee the country so they're
like we're gone
go ahead bro yes so the question is man
I've watched the grind and I'm running
my own business now ecommerce drop
shipping business and a digital
marketing agency agencies literally
based on all the models that you've
shown up LinkedIn and itself your watch
and everything you do say doesn't work
but the question I have right now is my
two business partners they're mentors to
me they both in their 50s I'm only 28
and they tell me this all time was our
you gotta you gotta stop being a yes-man
or you gotta stop saying things that you
know people want to hear and I'm not I
mean I'm in the trenches every day I'm
working I'm grinding I don't know if it
was
be specific to me on that way I feel
like I'm hurt I don't I don't know I
feel like I always put other people's
not opinions but their feelings I guess
above mine right I don't like I do too
yeah and I feel like it affects me in a
negative way maybe not immediately but
maybe down the road or the relationships
or the reverse potentially I guess so
yeah let's play it out we'll give me a
real light cuz I like where you're going
here listen I think we can help you and
a lot of people so I'm interested in
this give me a black and white go real
with me get a little naked
give me a real-life example of the whole
[ __ ] give me the okay all right man
here you go here's put it all up one of
my clients is a luxury dealership in
Michigan here auto dealership and it
started off we're just running Facebook
dynamic ads for him it started really
working and then he started you know the
GM the owner started asking hey what
else can you do can you do a little more
they do a little more and it was kind of
just give give give and hey it was my
first big client and starting the
business so you were doing more things
for the same scope or were you yes more
money yes I wasn't asking for more money
okay whatever I did was kind of brushed
off okay and it's gotten to the point
where I feel like it's a more of an
employee rather than you know the
marketing arm from or their agency yeah
which I feel like I did that to myself
though you did but that's okay I don't
think that's bad let me ask you the
other questions you've become very
valuable to them oh yeah I can I could
sense that for sure I can too without
knowing [ __ ] so let's keep talking do
you have other clients yeah so what we
have two other budgets what yeah what
percentage of your overall business do
they control my partners or nope know me
Oh client this client fee in your
overall business do some quick math oh
man that's the things it's huge I'd say
how much price 50% of our revenue that's
coming in so you need to spend every
waking hour continuing to eat [ __ ] and
bring them value and every minute of
your life landing
other clients every minute okay how do I
ask for referrals with them like you
don't don't know don't put them in a box
we're gonna put them on a shelf okay
they're over here no resentment okay
they've been fifty percent of your
revenue yeah like you've subconsciously
strategically over delivered because
that's giving you stickiness absolutely
I love what you're doing okay
the only part of the story that I don't
like so far is I want you to make them
eight percent or twelve percent of your
revenue right so I want you to slowly
not fear them going away and okay I'd
like take a little of the energy and a
lot of energy away from your leisure
your weekends your other time yeah 100%
strategy to make them much smaller but
percentage your business mm-hmm and once
they become twenty percent of your
business I'm ready to go back to them
and say the gig is up and I need to ask
for a twenty five to fifty percent 100
percent increase okay and if not we're
going to have to part ways what kind of
contract do you have with them uh it's
it was a six-month contract and we after
the six months we just pushed it in once
a month so it's even better yeah even
better people see that as like you got
[ __ ] I see that as you've won oh I want
you to make it twenty percent you need
me oh you love the advice mom thanks mom
all that cheerleading I feel you need to
make it twenty percent of your business
and then you go in and now you have the
leverage and now they get scared that
you actually walk and then you have the
ability to walk awesome and then at that
moment when they represent eighteen
percent of your business that's when you
have to walk okay okay okay the guest
man's right just try just continue doing
what I'm doing that late just my
personality I guess I understand yes man
I think you you know I think you're I
think they're demonizing a strategic I
think you did everything right except
amortize out their leverage yeah awesome
isn't
when you're in the service business you
are in the yes business right right and
that's what I think I got to where I'm
at
I say yes to all my clients all the time
yeah until I don't but you have that the
leverage to not absolutely one last
quick one last quick question how do I
get unlocked out of Facebook man I was
creating an ad last night midnight
literally finished the entire ad put in
my payment and then I got locked out of
Facebook it's asking from dude I don't
know it's asking for my ID I uploaded it
checked all use right it's an email send
me an email to Gary at vaynermedia I'll
get my media team to help you oh you the
man
all right let's keep going
keep it go and Kevin's back so keV what
is no problem rather hey it's by
treating him like an adult and saying
look this may happen what's his name
Brady Brady listen literally sit down
you know coffee driving however you guys
roll buddy listen something on my mind
you know I'm so proud of you and your
[ __ ] crushing it but one thing that
has run through my mind Brady and I want
you to feel comfortable at having this
talk with me is I'm I am but I'm
potentially because you're a young man
and a lot of things are gonna evolve but
potentially you I find that you being so
good at this that you figured out a
system and it's safe that I want to make
sure that you're happy not just
financially successful and I I hope you
know that there you know there's other
ways to go about it than just going to a
safe job that pays off and I'm just
seeing what Brady does the other thing
in parallel is are there other things
that Brady's interested in yeah I mean
he's despite the fact that he doesn't go
in school he's a normal teenager right I
mean great let's call it duty he loves
Robert she's three Sport athlete so you
know telling telling him that you you
know talk to Gary B today the owner of
the Minnesota rocker called duty team do
you like want to work for that team one
day or do you want to be an eSports
fight like it's you creating enormous
conversation around a hey don't just and
it's not like don't make if you make it
not Brady I'm worried you're gonna mail
it in it comes so easy to you and you're
gonna live
that's more like dad wants me to be
ambitious if you really put it in the
position of like hey I want you to be
happy and you might find yourself at 41
realizing you went safe the whole time
and you may have resent or unhappiness I
care about your happiness not how
successful you are we're kids getting
bucked and we're parents get [ __ ] is
all the conversation is around how
successful a cake but eventually they
are or status not happy and I think
you're aiming down a happy path and I
think if you keep pounding the happy
path and place a Oreo play like hey
Brady would you rather be you know a
lawyer making six hundred thirty
thousand a year or a Call of Duty
marketing executive and making 129 and
just having those talks with him I need
to navigate those combos does that make
sense no it makes perfect sense I think
that's exactly what we've started to do
with him and what have you see heard
that so since you know heard it a little
bit is he just classic closed off and
like whatever dad or is he kind of like
cleaning in like what's happening
no his struggle is that he he he likes
to learn and he is good at certain like
for the example the other day he said to
me he's like you know I'm thinking about
being an engineer because I'm pretty
good at math and I should probably do
something with that and I'm like you
know maybe not you know what fine let's
tired about that play with me on this
say baby that's cool you could also you
know you can also day trade stocks Brady
you could also run masa analytics for
the government around defense like like
what you want to do in that sense is not
let him just pick one option with it you
need to almost educate yourself on what
math infrastructure is on everything or
Brady you could be the CFO a back
division you know kind of going into his
world why don't you be the CFO of the
Knicks or you know like what's his
favorite sports team sorry sorry again
what's his favorite sports team
wasn't me he he just I think he lost
connection okay next one we'll bring him
back three-part series yeah what's good
hey how you doing today I'm really well
how are you Scott oh I'm all right um my
my question is I turned 49 on Saturday
thanks where do you find your passion or
your why how do you do that I I'm a
factory worker and I've always thought
all my life I've tried different aspects
to find something that gave me a reason
to get out of bed excited or even wanted
to get out of bed
I understand how do you do that where do
you play let's play okay let's go let's
go into the mindset of the following
what what do you tend to like to do when
you're not working
last year's sleep right because you're
poor choice you know I get it cuz you're
depressed and you're you're like not in
that great place but that's okay well I
don't want to use this in as an excuse
I've an excuse I deal clinical
depression I've been for 15 years tried
to find different medications and
nothing's worked so basically my
medication for my depression is watching
videos like yours and other motivational
figures and this and is that work that
entertains you that makes you feel like
you're living vicariously through it you
feel like that one video might get you
going you're looking for it like what
how does that ride for you well yeah it
just kind of gives me that okay there's
something better out there there's you
know there's something well there is
I'm it's done you know what's cool and
it's not about you missing a couple
things you're gonna really like this
answer brother the first thing I need
you to do with all my heart
is realize how much you have an entire
another life to live you need to know
that you've been like from the day you
were born - today is the amount of time
minimum ly you're probably in the
ballpark on what you're gonna live what
why I think that's important is that
Scott you and I grew up in a generation
where
when we were 16 17 like 4944 seemed like
a thousand right right but now that
we're here it's like wait a minute like
it's not that thousand like there's
still some real life to go so I think
first and foremost you have to realize
how much is in front of you and it
actually doesn't matter the last 15
years
what happened from 34 back it actually
doesn't and what I mean by that is and
why I'm so excited we're here together
brother I really am I'm really genuinely
passionately optimistic about this
moment is I think we're gonna spend a
few minutes here and like chip away and
I understand I talked to a lot of people
theoretically in in different scenarios
that may be similar
maybe because everyone's got different
nuances stick with me here so look away
couple let's take away the last couple
years let's take away the motivational
videos in general whether it's sports or
music or food well is give me a history
lesson of ska do like of things that
you've kind of liked wrestling boxing
like anything ah you know I've tried to
find that answer myself and you know I I
used to love to camp and stuff like that
you know when I was younger I was in the
military I was pretty physically active
I was always on a go I was not one that
just said I couldn't sit I was always on
a go in the last 10 15 years there's
been nothing I you know nothing I have
nothing that I can find that just gets
me that once you know might makes me
want to pick up and go talk to me
positive or negative I don't have much
manner circle yeah in fact you know just
for example I had four happy birthday
wishes one was my wife one was my
ex-wife
then my stepson and my son and in that
order and you know that was about it so
you know I don't I used to have more of
a circle I enjoy being around people I
generally just I don't I'm not a people
person anymore
I understand because you know when when
it when inside it's not a good thing
it's hard to like make outside work
right I totally have empathy for that
let me ask
you know other questions do you have do
you have any social media accounts just
a Facebook account and are you active on
it that's usually where I get my video
content do you comment uh occasionally
not a lot um positive or more razzing
well I don't
I usually don't comment unless someone
is like attacking someone for something
and then and then I jump in I love that
you defend people yeah I well that's
something that that's one thing and I've
always done I've always liked to help
people and stand up for the little guy
that's that's just my thing
me too I like that I like that I like
the little Robin Hood or like the bully
buster
well sometimes it has to be done I agree
my man I'm just so genuinely happy
you're on here with me um what what
here's a good one
what in my content has resonated with
you if anything you know I think the
biggest thing is you just seem to UM you
know you're not judgmental I mean you're
straightforward I like that I like the
fact that you don't sugarcoat nothing
you know I by myself if you got
something to say to me I just want the
truth you know I know I don't be easy
with me but don't be gentle but I think
that you generally are trying to help
people and you're not necessarily trying
to do it to benefit yourself yeah you
know hey thank you you clearly have good
emotional intelligence you're right
and like and and I just like like I'm in
that like you should I wish everybody
could feel my chemicals right now in
this moment because I'm so happy and I'm
so conscious because I genuinely believe
that through words amazing things can
happen like you know first of all I
think it's you know I think it's nice to
have for family and X you know X Y you
know like sudden like like four is
better than zero right right I really
mean that there's just an ungodly amount
I'm just very grateful to I appreciate
you saying I'm not judgmental that meant
a lot to me it was a very good
observation because you also follow it
up with being can Duras
and trying to shoot it because it's Kyle
be honest with you man like life is so
fun you know what this makes me think a
lot about momentum I think a lot about
momentum I think about it all the time
you know I love sports so like
basketball super funny you know I don't
know if you've ever watched it or you
follow it but like you know one team can
go on a thirty no run then there's a
timeout you kind of gather yourself then
that team can go on a big run the other
run and I think life is about momentum
and I think I think a lot about fear too
I you know I was very fear based in a
lot of things as a kid like swimming
riding bikes kissing a girl they were
scary to me and I was late I was a late
bloomer across the board on all three of
those things and then and then you do it
and it becomes normalized and like
reason like one of the things I'm
running through my you know I'm talking
to you on the corner of my eye right
over here there's a scream of like
10,000 people that like want to be your
friend
you can't see it it's a much it's in the
live teams I've got a stream that shows
me Julie and then Lisette and MB and
Oded and Scarlett all on YouTube
Facebook and Twitter all like I love
this guy I want to be Scott's friend I
root for this guy I want he said sir and
so I sit here and I'm like man it's
connect like this is just a good
old-fashioned game of like positive
energy momentum like in the same you're
34 when this kicked in like you said for
the last 15 years right right yeah I
gotta tell you I'm come and I mean this
Scott I am completely commenced with my
entire soul that this is the moment that
it can just start in the other direction
that that's mom here for that's what I'm
looking for I'm looking for that one
thing that just gives me that let's go
so Scott are you willing to share your
email so all these people who are into
hiking and outdoors men and maybe
hunting or fishing like like that's the
Attucks like what I'm playing here we're
playing and you could say no to anything
you know I go into okay he's given me
some context that he used to like that I
won where do you live uh Indiana
Rensselaer Indiana
um you know like art you know to me back
to like I was scared to kiss a girl but
then you do it like to me it's like
what's what's going through my mind to
be transparent it's like
Scott go on a hunting trip with or like
fishing trip with like a stranger that
he done met on Facebook got a little
more comfortable to the FaceTime because
they email him right now and he does it
and that becomes a trigger to something
he's liked at a new social graph how
does that resonate in her head
well you know um a phishing I've always
found very boring I'm and and I I don't
look down on people that hunt you know
it's it doesn't bother me I'm not a
hunter myself I just you know I can't
kill animals you know in fact I really
like animals more than I do people
because they're not judgmental exactly I
don't have a problem with meeting new
people I'm just I don't want to say that
I am afraid to meet new people I just I
just don't know the words to use about
people right now yeah I guess I guess
I've just been let down so many times by
people and it's like I've isolated
myself Scott you can't be let down when
you don't have expectations let's play
with that for a minute
okay well so I've been let down on paper
an ungodly amount of times because of
the way I do business similar to the kid
earlier where I give give give right and
a lot of times it doesn't get
reciprocated however I take on full
accountability on my gift and I think
it's I think that this is an important
insight I think that one thing to think
about back to the next 49 years is if
you don't have expectations to what
you're giving truly I mean this and it's
not so easy like I'm not shooting it
like but one of the things that's really
works for me is the ability to calibrate
expectations I'm too much empathy and
sympathy and compassion for other human
beings to expect them to put me in front
of themselves right and in a weird way
that realization allows me to put other
people in front of my own self and has
created a very charismatic kind good
energy that is sustainable for me
because I'm not disappointed or
judgmental right
and so you know for example what's
really weird about this meta moments got
again back to tens of thousands of
people watching this is if you if you
allow me to have you share your email
and if you actually go on face times and
zooms and email and talk on Facebook
messenger with these hundreds of people
that are set up to talk to you you
should see what's going on here people
are like in love with you you know don't
forget the context of you meeting them
is you being this transparent about you
know you know that worry or things that
nature you I am blown away by how many
people are golden hearted but I think it
takes two to tango you also have to work
on yourself on expectations I I
completely agree with that
thank you no I am yeah it's just you
need positive people in your life I get
that and I'm so scared that you meet
someone you think maybe they're positive
and then they get you yeah I get it you
know and then dragged you further down
negatively and that is why I think if
you go into this next chapter maybe with
this vaynernation community which is
look people don't like me you know I
mean there's a lot a lot of people
follow me at first because they think I
can help to make more money but like
people that are watching right now 85%
of them have a level of humanity and
kindness that I think is elevated from
the norm of content on the Internet and
so I have so much confidence in this
community that I'm you know I'm sure you
like I just feel I feel like really
excited this I'll be very transparent
he's got we've been doing this for a
couple of weeks now maybe a month or it
feels like who knows but there isn't
even a close second to my favorite call
this and we've had some barn burgers on
here cuz I'm completely convinced as my
chemicals bounce in my body that
something incredible is gonna happen
here I I hope so and I you know I I
didn't get send my question so I could
talk to you about finances I mean
granted I would I would love to be
better financially i but that's not
what I need that's not important to me
I'm not super important to me me neither
even though I have the talent to produce
it I trust me good news I know that's
not white that's not why you're here I
on the flip side think there's no room
that you could have been in better than
this one for what you actually do need
and I I I think this community and I
think why you've been attracted to me is
um it's just all playing out you know
Scott I think about this all the time
people talk about you know covet and
groan of being such a terrible event and
that's absolutely true we've seen right
death tolls that make us all shiver down
our spines I'd be lying if I didn't tell
you that I'm incapable of not seeing the
silver lining and the optimism and this
there is no chance in hell that you and
I have these 20 minutes anyway ever
without COBIT it's just not who I was
navigating my life what I did askgaryvee
or a podcast I would be in such a tight
short window that I would have to cut it
off cut it short the level of depth I'm
able to do on this show is so different
I I genuinely believe in my soul right
now that your life will never be the
same after this I genuinely believe that
and and I and I think that that's
amazing as a collateral as an impact for
what happened in the macro and that
makes me happy and that's how I think
about the world right and like I said
you know I'm not scared to meet new
people and move forward I'm just nervous
I think two things have to happen one
you have to do two very important things
number one we're gonna share your email
here and you have to do two things for
me one I mean you have to work on
yourself to not have expectations you
have to be okay with Lisette or Johnny
or Stevie or skewed or Matthew or Jenn
stick to be okay with like worrying
about themselves to do you know what I
mean okay you have to be okay with that
you have to be selfless in their
selfishness at the same token you also
have to be very awake to knowing that
the people that are about to reach out
in this community are already starting
on third and a half base around kindness
compassion cuz they've also
a lot of context out of you in this call
I think you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah I'm ready I mean let's do it what's
your email uh lone rider
Scott you don't like number one number
one passion in life right now is from a
year from now for you to send me an
email and say yo I changed my email own
rider to Scott's gang at gmail.com that
couldn't you couldn't have that was
literally out of central casting I love
you with all my heart right now for now
I can email I don't know I just it's a
good scene right now you know what's
funny it is the perfect segue for this
call it is going to be the last time
that email is going to really mean
anything because I think that email is
gonna start the process of that email
changing over time so go ahead let's put
it up lone rider 71 at gmail.com Dustin
do your thing let's make sure it's right
let's make sure you know that's it
it's got listen to me if you work on
yourself around not expecting anything
from all these incredible people that
are emailing you right now and everybody
was emailing listen Scott's gonna have
to make some decisions here let's be
empathetic you can't just be like hey I
want to be your friend you need to right
where you live what kind of interest you
have you know do you wanna you know
what's your facebook so you can go and
messenger like or are you or you what do
you do like are you and paintballing are
you in gardening you need to pitch our
friend here Scott does this friendship
is valuable and so he's gonna pick some
here it's got him really excited about
this well I I appreciate you taking a
time I really do it means more to me
than you probably will ever know you
know it's funny I hear that at different
times I really do know like people need
people you know I'm down to you and back
to your point of like well I haven't
been able to do that because you haven't
been in the best place I'm so grateful
and he and I'd be frank with you
it's got also
back to chemicals and how this all works
there's probably a in that 80% gratitude
there's 20% guilt I'm aware that I could
have had a DNA trait that acted even
this is not just like hey pick it up
these are these are diseases and
sicknesses real life right so it so I
have so much good I want to put this
energy I'm Scott I'm telling you right
now to your beautiful face which I love
your [ __ ] goatee by the way I'm
telling my now brother
to [ __ ] your pants this is gonna be good
you probably actually can you check your
Gmail right now just give me an update
on me else you got
yeah everybody hope you've been paying
attention make sure you wish him a happy
birthday he's gonna go for a four to
four thousand I just want to get a sense
of how many emails you've got ah oh [ __ ]
they're still coming in look at the top
does it say at the top
well it says 12 so far but I haven't
checked my email in a couple days but
yeah I got like buy more just in it last
three seconds mom you're gonna have a
very very very very very very busy and
exciting day I think so yeah and I think
it's gonna change your life
once again I just thank you you're
welcome all right what's your well take
care of sorry good get back to all those
emails to me Scott
alright thank you you're welcome let's
keep it going
third time's a charm Gary it always is
brother
yeah I literally drove to my friend's
office because I think like I said I got
four kids and their jam in the water
right now they're jamming school yeah um
I think we I think we're their cab you
know I think I think I think what you
want to do is paint him pictures that
don't make his world narrow roads like
so maybe I'll be a developer and then
you could say well maybe you'll be the
CFO of the of the piece or you know what
it was like right like I think you need
to really push him into dreaming
opportunities where he's like he's being
practical around a skill set you know
but that skill set of math translates in
a million different ways yeah exactly
and can layer to things that he finds
more fun which will then give him energy
which will then drive him to levels of
success and Happiness that are far
greater than just taking a practical
route right I mean here's a different
way that I may be asked it it's like how
do you manage a kid and manage it the
right word but you know Shepard will
call it a kid who is frankly perfectly
designed at least by all accounts to
play the game that is education right
now
right but it's not over fearing it
because you and I share our ideology of
like what the school system is not over
fearing it right and by transposing that
skill into things that make him happy
okay does that make sense yeah no I
think it makes sense I could just we be
careful we have to be careful to not
over demonize school right the way that
we grew up where I was put on a pedestal
you how old are you my friend 45 right
so we're the same age I'm 44 25 this
year you know what I'm about to say
there was no [ __ ] other option tell
these kids that are watching there
wasn't a lot right nor [ __ ] it was go to
college right and if you don't go to a
good college there's a very big chance
you won't be happy and successful right
right the whole million dollar more
number that they threw around all the
time
so now
now we're in a great spot but I we need
to be careful to not over demonize it
either right and I think you need to tap
into his interest I love the three
sports call a duty stuff like love it
like yeah and and really also throw some
things at him do some weird [ __ ] once in
a while like you know take him to a
cooking class and be like I know this
blows and I know you hate me but like
let's just talk sports the whole time
for the two hours and maybe god forbid
you're actually destined to be the
greatest chef of all time yeah it's a
good point yeah push it up yeah yeah
like and by the way like push and then
let go maybe like it's real life like
never get too caught always be well he's
willing to adjust you booked the cooking
class 200 bucks each and then he just
[ __ ] like just as devastated and then
you're like [ __ ] it [ __ ] the 400 bucks
and you let him out of it
that doesn't mean that he's not seeing
it through that means you took a shot at
an innovation and didn't work that kind
of stuff he's who everyone yeah no I get
it I mean we're we're big on that as
parents I mean back to the call of duty
thing it was or any video games when he
was younger it was always you know let
him play the video games because he's
doing everything else fine academically
and if we just kept pushing the
academics pushing academics he doesn't
know anything other than academics so
let him go with it let him you know now
it's the 3.0 version of that now I have
more intellectual theoretical
conversations with him to expand his
mind yeah no I like that okay good good
effort Deb's Rove to [ __ ] another plan
man I respect that heightened what's
good Mike Z what's good to accrete
what's good be adventurous what's good
and repairs on what's good
Kim Jacobs looks good oh we haven't done
a wine text thing let's put it up we
haven't done an all-in challenge thing
we're gonna end with all unchallenged
today again just got that cute uh yeah I
still have it um I wasn't sure if we
were going till 11:00 or not okay just
checking
[Music]
wine texts dot-com it is uh thank you
green juice wine text comm if you buy
wine on the internet or you buy wine at
total wine or batma or if you buy wine
and you're not signed up for this you
are breaking my dad's heart you're
breaking my heart
oh I check this out I was making some
commercials we're making some ads
commercials some apps old ads for social
media they're you know like this watch
so I'm making some ads for us so making
some ads for for social check this out
this is gonna hit your Facebook and it's
a very extreme tell me what you think I
love it
hey please please please please sign up
for wine text calm it would mean the
world to me if you're like literally
sixty dollar wine for 30 bucks for deep
dollar wine for fourteen bucks it is
literally the best best best wine
service in the world it's easy it takes
two minutes to sign up it takes two
seconds to order it's super fun it's
only 365 deals it's the it's the best
it's the [ __ ] best so please please
and if you don't drink if you go to if
you go to your Facebook account right
now and say anybody who drinks wine sign
up for wine texts that would mean the
world to me as well let's watch it over
time cuz everybody loved it
hold your mic closer to the phone
[Music]
my dad's doing make my dad happy like
when my dad gets sign up like literally
people signing up for wine texts by the
way don't sign up for it just to make my
dad happy because if you don't buy
anything it costs money to send a text
so we don't need that but if you try if
you drink wine it would mean the world
to me
alright let's keep it going oh my gosh
oh my god hey how are you I'm well
that's awesome I'm doing well as well
umm duty I'm doing let's do it
so first off I just want to say thank
you for having me on this show but for
more importantly you're changing lives
man and right no you are you just
changed people's lives in a way that I
think is absolutely fantastic and if I'm
being real with you what I feel like my
purpose on this earth is to connect
deeply with people and inspire them to
live a more meaningful life and so much
of that has been influenced by your
teaching has been influenced by others
and is really just I look up to you as
someone I want to do what you're doing
um yeah of course so do you have the
patience to pull it off because the
thing that absolutely the thing that
you'll need to do is do things that
build up the credibility for the
messaging tool and absolutely I
absolutely believe in that and it's not
something it's not a tomorrow thing it's
something that I'm doing for the rest of
my life if this is what I'm going to be
doing and maybe I make it one of 80
years old and I make a difference in
someone's life that's what I'm here for
and that's what I'm gonna be gone for it
so my question thank you my question
today is I'm been struggling to kind of
find a path that aligns with that vision
so I'm a high school senior I'm about to
graduate and I'm trying to really feel
how did everybody feel about like what's
the top vibe how many kids you have in
your collage winning class we have about
600 maybe a little more yeah yeah what
are you doing those were a New Jersey
move
Pillsbury New Jersey yeah lie you know
that I went to North hundred in high
school no witness no High has six
hundred [ __ ] kids graduating from me
oh yeah yeah we are packed we do not
have room for it but we have them do
they still have like a football trophy
for Ricky Proehl the wide receiver who
Katie do you know that we're like 20
minutes apart right this minute I'm
insane what what's the vibe was
everybody like devastated about prom and
graduation
absolutely absolutely people are just
devastated about it and it's go ahead
I'm sorry no no it's totally good it's
just totally changed not only our senior
year but our outlook for what we're
doing next year which is totally so like
for me this kind of gets into my
question so I've been kind of my focus
has been one optimizing for a great
experience after high school and really
just connecting with people who are
going to push me towards the path that
I'm supposed to take and for me those
two options have kind of narrowed down
to either taking a gap year or going
straight to the college that I'm
accepted to but if at UVM University
Vermont yep so I'm kind of in-between
these two circumstances but coronavirus
has really added this extra level of
frustration because my gap year and my
freshman experience could look totally
freaking different that's yeah no
foundation no what if you're gonna do
what you want to do and your energy so
awesome and everyone's loving you in the
comments you need to understand that
plans are [ __ ] have a plan but but the
ability to adjust to reality is the
ultimate let me tell you this what I've
been doing I actually had a conversation
with one of my mentors who works at Ted
so it's my dream to work at Ted TED
Talks you know all of that one of my big
dreams to work there so I'm totally
passionate about their vision and really
aligned with their
mission so I don't know if she's still
the CEO but I might people you need to
email me at Gary a vaynermedia yeah I
still know the president I don't know it
holds the job but she clearly knows a
lot of people there and I might be able
to help you so that'd be fantastic I
will I will not forget but I was talking
to one of my mentors who actually works
at Ted and we're basically everything in
my life I try and look through the lens
of everything for me not against me so
what I try and do is to if something
happens Khurana okay how can we make
this entreaty I then I need you to stay
true to that and not say frustrated
about the gap year [ __ ] Vermont Bay
yeah no you're absolutely right and I go
yeah here like yours with you because I
see the potential in you yes thank you
you're welcome
your energy is just sweet and [ __ ]
awesome thank you but then you need to
listen to me right now
yeah like [ __ ] that frustration don't
get caught up in a bubble of what you're
supposed to feel you're not for us
absolutely I can hear it this is an
important part of the evolution this is
the training we're on some Jedi [ __ ] now
yeah yeah I actually don't believe that
you're frustrated no I'm not I'm excited
about it but you're parroting words from
others you're taking the energy from the
ones that are yeah that's true that's
true so that's why we need to focus on
this moment because this is a good way
for you to do it let's do it
no more sarin no more parroting other
energy [ __ ] truth you owe me the gap
your whole [ __ ] life Katie yeah no I
was looking at that that's definitely
like gap your meaning doing what that
[ __ ] you want
absolutely and I'm still trying to
figure out what exactly that looks like
right now I'm a personal development
don't don't don't
I'll let you finish in a minute but
don't know don't put it into process you
already know exactly what it looks like
you just told me what you're gonna do I
always knew I was gonna do it too
you know what my process looked like I
worked in my dad's liquor store for 15
years
absolutely and do you think you think is
the right clear path to [ __ ] image like
to impacting people's lives
carrying [ __ ] cases of Korbel Brut
into people you know no back seats no
yeah if you're into patience then you're
not overvaluing process upfront yeah
absolutely no one to fall in love with
that process is something that I've been
definitely holding court to who I'm
trying to become and you know what I'm
basically telling you what it's not
gonna matter whatever that is it doesn't
matter if you go to Vermont or if you go
to a gap year if you're an intern at Ted
or if you work at a coffee shop in Aspen
or if you go in a car with your friends
and drive cross-country or if you go to
Ireland for three years if it's your
destiny if it's what you're about you
will absolutely process through and so
whether you have an Instagram account
that has 43 followers on it or not
whether you go viral epic talk or not
whether you execute on the thing that
happens in 19 years from now that's
invented by somebody you we haven't even
started and you need to stay on the
macro mission and not overvalue the
micro mission yeah the office is
actually it's just not gonna matter ya
know and I totally agree with that I
think that was something I was as I was
preparing for this show I kind of I got
to that in a way of saying you know what
I have this purpose and really I think
people look for the perfect place to
live out their mission and really even
do your purpose you can do your mission
literally wherever you're going and
that's really important you doing it
right now yeah absolutely absolutely I'm
super excited about it thank you you're
welcome
how do you paint me a picture and it
will change 39 times so no pressure
people I serve exactly what you're doing
when you're 44 know exactly what I'm
doing when I'm 44 ha take just a great I
want to be traveling and meeting people
helping people going to hopefully I will
amass a large amount of knowledge and
skills that can help people and add
value to their lives hello
Wow Gary you dropped off for a second I
did my back yeah your back okay cool
okay bye hey sorry are you so you have
this incredible framework of
selflessness thank you
you're welcome which I also have do you
what is selfish to you do you want
statues do you want to be famous
do you want money no all of these are
okay do not analyze them what what do
you think you want and/or need so I know
that you don't give me don't give me
some altruistic selflessness man you
want to help you go ahead
alright so I know that I need enough
money to live the life of my dreams so
what that means is having experiences
that I think are freakin amazing and
that energize me that I think are
vibrant that recognize like is that
going to like some weird mountain in
Peru and like drink oh yeah oh yeah of
like some rare fruit animal like you're
into that food yes doing all of it it's
do it Baron Singh life to the absolute
like highest what how do you define that
is it in the form of food like I'm a
foofy guy but I don't need to go to some
mountain and hang with some gurus and
silence and drink like baby urine but
some people love that [ __ ] like are you
about the urine or or not like you love
that [ __ ] like India in a cave for a
month's like and but on your feel like
are you into that I think some of that I
think pushing my boundaries of what's
comfortable I think it's freaking
awesome so doing some of that is awesome
but I also want to be able to be
financially free I don't have to really
stress on there you want people you want
people to pay you as their coach I'm not
sure if that's the way that I make my
money and that's what gives me the
financial freedom I need then absolutely
think that's great does it run through
your mind of starting a sentence like
life is good and building like a five
million dollar a year hoodie company
does that one thing your mind ever
definitely does definitely into like I'm
even getting back to this idea of
optimizing the experience of what can we
do with coronavirus I had this idea to
basically how can we recreate the
freshman experience in a virtual space
where you're only kind of creative
constraint is the fact that every
thing has to be online so again it's
creating those random collisions it's
creating those deep connections those
deep conversations with new people so it
definitely had thoughts like that of
creating something a program a business
something like that I love it Katie I'm
I'm gonna tell you something I hope you
rewatch over and over yeah 100% gonna
win life thank you I'm thank you I'm
positive
yeah thank you positive keep it simple
keep it open
I like your framework I like your energy
yeah well how many people follow you on
Instagram not a lot I have maybe 83 83
followers thank you thank you and I do
have a question feel free to say no no
problem but I'm here I don't one of you
follow five people that fires me up you
know that's my number yeah all of five
people
you follow five people yeah NASA
manifested minds
Ted education National Geographic and me
yeah that's cool thank you man watch
this kitty yeah
you've already doubled thank you thank
you I'm definitely gonna continue doing
this mission um but I gotta say I have
this moment to be bold so I'm gonna be
it okay you talked about finding a
leader who's doing what you want to be
doing and working them for free yeah you
also said to find someone and say what
can I do for you I'm hungry so garyvee
what can I do for you I'm hungry uh can
you create because we're gonna be hiring
absolutely like are you writer you know
my content generator yeah I do
all right so I mean email I'm I would
tell you right now that you have a
significant chance of being able to get
a job with me absolutely thank you so
much thank you so much but you know what
city you might not want that job because
right now you're you're already up to
278 I feel like you're gonna be that's
that before this video is over I mean I
know I'm gonna introduce you to Ted and
I'm gonna introduce you to Andy Kay who
runs my team I'm gonna vet your creative
talents
cuz right now on Team Gary we're not
only hiring makers people that could
make me make content for LinkedIn yeah
but yeah either you have to design make
videos or right yeah so uh I'm into it
absolutely you know Gary Boehner mean
you put Katie from tea time and New
Jersey plus Dustin will get connected
with you actually work with dust that
Dustin you can take care of that right
okay I got you
Katie Katie look 3:53 Katie yeah thank
you thank you so much you're welcome
keep going talk to you soon yeah thank
you so much bye-bye
it's a good episode yeah
hi Gary say where you from where you
from camp I am thank you for everything
first art I'm always grateful for for
everything you do bringing that value
you saved my life numerous times and I
couldn't be more than grateful for that
seriously thank you you're welcome
I'm originally from Peru born and raised
oh my god I just said [ __ ] yeah I know
how the [ __ ] this is see cam this is why
out of all the [ __ ] things when I'm
painting the weird picture to Katie I
say Peru out of any [ __ ] place on
earth and then you're not yeah [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] fufu [ __ ] that [ __ ]
with me oka this [ __ ] with me cam this
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me you know hi man
it's so deep man it's so deep so just
like with you you know you're an
immigrant I was an immigrant for years
matter of fact I can't when I first came
here I got to go back as my dad you know
he was doing crazy things so when I came
back my mom remarried and I was still
working on my paperwork getting my green
card finally what's they would've do
that
so as forwarding school is not for me
but I was still an A and B student but I
ended up dropping out because of me lost
camp I'm still here I'm still here
ended up dropping out because I'm still
here I'm with you okay can you hear me
yep yep I can hear him okay
awesome I can't really hear you though
know we lost that part cam truck just
reloading the page wait wait can you can
you hear Dustin but not me you know I
don't think she can hear me
yeah camp can you actually just reload
the page and then come back in sure yeah
okay you could hear me but you probably
can't ya Mary cam can you hear me okay
I'll reload the page I guess I'll stay
here for a second well thank you Justin
for hearing entertained while to see
somebody so doesn't the fufu stuff like
that was [ __ ] crazy
well you did you know cam was from Peru
no she actually mentioned it in the
comments and I was like I'm pretty sure
we're in a simulation
[Laughter]
well you argue your [ __ ] 35 and you
look 3.5 km alright so go ahead anyway
dropping out long story short there I
got into I'll get into the media
business right and I was doing promoting
for music festivals traveling and doing
things like that but my mom it's just my
mom here living now she's divorced
there's a lot of things going on it just
like you helped your dad build this
incredible business I feel the same way
you know that's all my family's in Peru
all of them and me I feel like there's
all this responsibility on my shoulders
to create the wealth necessary and I'm
not I mean I love the financial industry
because I saw that you know and and I
got into that at first I was like you
know what it's just gonna work out I'm
all about marketing but I fell in love
with it and you know now just wanting to
create that look for my family building
a legacy and wanted to obviously go back
to Peru helping out children there
helping out you know children here in
our community as well my question is
good I want to hear it yeah my question
is being pretty much the person who is
leading the way of my not just you know
with my legacy that I want to create
from
family I know that it took a long time
for you to build that business for your
dad and right now obviously you know my
family's broke you know my family's
broken I'm over here thinking all right
I'm in this new business with them Jim
you're gonna lose if you want to go fast
that's my question I know I almost
interrupted you I already have the
answer the answer is slow and that goes
countercultural because every day that
goes by is another day that you envision
them struggling exactly well cam I'm
gonna throw a real bomb at you that you
as an immigrant know and a lot of other
people here who've come from immigrant
or humble beginnings they're not
struggling as much as you think yeah
because when your context is your life
then your life is your context you don't
even you now know what you want them to
have here in America but they haven't
tasted that yet so you're creating an
ideology of pressure like I've got to
get my grandma my mom my aunt over here
so they can have it good in America but
they're not struggling as much as you
create in your mind cuz that's the
reality
I wasn't struggling when I had way less
I was happy yeah and you can try to go
fast you're gonna cut corners and
actually lose but that's how I feel
about the situation I'm new to the you
have to we you have to reframe the
situation if your perspective is that
you have to go fast for them instead of
you have to go slow to ever pull it off
and that these next three years they'll
still be super fine because that's where
they're from that's what they know yeah
yes you understand this is where
immigrants in America always get caught
but Gary I gotta get my family here I'm
like how bad is it are they like in jail
are they in a dangerous zone are they in
a war zone a drug zone and nine out of
ten times they're not they're like yeah
but they're running water I'm like but
they've always known the running water
wasn't great
yeah but they you know I want to have
new clothes I'm like but they've lived
in the same clothes forever
like we can't impose a capitalistic
wealthiest country on were in the world
on them because their content of course
they'd love to be here more because they
just miss you not because they want to
eat a [ __ ] Shake Shack yeah no
exactly I know I miss them I haven't
seen them in 13 years you you need to go
back and see them you need to worry
about going slow and flipping some [ __ ]
on eBay to save for a plane ticket not
to [ __ ] win the lottery you're going
for the Hail Mary
exactly exact you could have seen them
twice if you had the perspective I'm
trying to have you have this is about
you [ __ ] bringing them over and
having a mansion that everybody lives
into that's a that's a that's your ego
talking no you're absolutely right you
know and and of course I'm obviously
going to work hard and believe it you
know obviously given my all develop
every single day so that I can become
that person that I ought to become and
just like you said listen to everything
that you mentioned the humility the
patience a strategy and you know I
definitely got to be patient you know
because right now I'm in the business
and everybody's going super fast you
know they're messaging
they're dealing people to 300 messages
and I'm over here thinking I don't want
to say I don't want to be a spam but at
the same time I don't know like how to
how to go about it you know how to go
about the bar by making content yeah I
mean content for so long before anybody
came
but you also can do side stuff you can
save money you can find money you know
that's why I love camp well I love the
flipping stuff if you got that in you
like that's the quickest way to make
$3,000 is goodwill and garage sales yeah
you know and immigrants have the
humility to go and drive and pick up
[ __ ] exactly exactly and right now you
know I actually did that matter of fact
I did flip a lot of things on offer up
let go I try to go big it went pretty
well I did saw some stuff um and I like
that concept of going out and you know
picking up random things and then
flipping it for more I'm telling you
right now every year you can go to Peru
every year you can go to Peru
if you garage sale every weekend for a
couple hours and ship out some stuff on
the week I'm telling you right now you
can yeah yeah and and I'm gonna do that
no seriously cuz I have to go back to
Peru and see my family
you probably do has to happen you have
to you you've got you want to go back
when you've already did something like
you try to be a hero just be a family
member I know and that's that's the
thing you know like every now and then
my mom is struggling so she asked us you
know for money and I'm obviously gonna
have it but my story my backside a story
I went homeless for almost two years and
you know I'm still decorating my
apartment was still trying to you know
obviously build myself up and build my
mind work you know my blueprint and so I
got into the business of insurance and
finances and I loved it you know I'm
learning more about money and things
like that now I'm not like oh you know I
have to like money is life happiness
it's not it's about the process you know
what you're doing for families too um
but that leads to this to the question
as well like everybody's going super
fast you know everybody's building up a
big team and I'm over here doing my
thing you know creating content branding
myself you know obviously providing as
much value as possible
but I don't know if that's a good
strategy to be DMing two to three
hundred people what here's the good news
why don't you PM a hundred people a day
offer some value do it a little less
spammy and see what it feels like when
you don't know the answer you have to do
what most people do in life is when they
don't know
answer they debate it in their own head
and do nothing they look at other people
who've done it and do whatever they said
without contextualizing how it impacts
them I don't want anybody to do anything
I say other than live their life fully
themselves the way I do and at least
hear out the tactics that I put out that
might bring value and see if it brings
value not debate if it does or blindly
believe that it does so the answer to
your question matters try it for a week
and see what it feels like and if you
feel spammy and goofy and ugly then stop
yeah you know many of my friends don't
like I like to eat exotic food I grew up
in the wine business so French cuisine
like foie gras and sweetbreads and all
sorts of weird Easter's I'm a very
exotic eater
and a lot of my when I'm out a lot of my
friends are business associates are like
oh I don't like oysters and you know
that more than half of them have never
had one really and that's how I think
about this you don't know what it feels
like to DM two hundred people a day so
you have to taste it
try it and give value to them right all
the value C I so it's it's not it's not
the tactic it's how you feel the tactic
exactly because I'm over here you know
learning about money too and I'm like
okay obviously financial literacy is
that you know very important um and
there's other things that come with it
like the leadership you know the the
built you know building up somebody and
things like that cuz I'm doing that
myself and I see a lot of people my age
who struggle people who went through the
same course of life and I'm like okay
like this is what I did you know this is
how that out of that situation how I
went from homeless to having at least at
home um in little things like that so
when I'm creating the content to help
people you know with the financial
literacy I know it's boring you know I
know it may be boring but you're not
black yeah you got it cam I trust you
Kim get to Peru for sure no I got to get
there I do Kim know
because you'll regret it when people
aren't there anymore when you go in six
years you need to go immediately yeah
this year that's good you have to be
practical I don't know what your money
situation is you have to figure it out
but I'm telling you right now flip life
I'm telling you right now flip life is
real yeah for sure for sure just about
being patient I'll continue listening to
your content mask I love everything you
do and you know being able to donate an
all end challenge like that's something
that I that I look forward to do someday
you know being able to help all these
children and people weren't hungry like
I grew up and that was like em Peru poor
country you know like I know that I get
it and I'm very passionate about this so
but overall I just I'm very grateful for
this moment thank you for giving me some
value I've gotta talk to you soon about
that suit on that if you don't know what
the almond challenge is right now all-in
challenge calm at the in a little bit
I'm gonna show you the video my offer is
crazy
the ultimate garyvee experience it's a
raffle $10 tickets to enter I fly you to
three of my keynotes you said front row
stand the greenroom with me I spend a
week with you at vaynermedia and work on
your content with my team Gary will and
I'm jump into a bunch of stuff you go
garage selling with me you go to a Jets
game with me and tailgating sit with me
I won't talk to you during the game
because that's how I roll
hmm twenty-five thousand dollar shopping
spree at Wine Library get to be on my
podcast it's going to be pretty legit so
check out all in challenge com Scorsese
and Leo are letting you be in their
movie Justin Bieber will come to your
home and serenade you there's some real
[ __ ] so all-in challenge calm please
check it out we've raised Jesus thirty
million dollars in a week watch the week
ago or actually not even six days ago
thirteen point four million dollars have
been raised and we're very proud of it
very proud I'm sure you've seen it all
over
celebrities athletes just been
unbelievably unbelievably incredible
let's think another one in
hey Gary what's up man what's up uncle
Pudge how you doing man has house
quarantine life it's going well yeah you
know I'm a big lemonade out of lemons
kind of guy and so that's where at 100%
yeah this this whole thing has really
helped me have some good quality time
with my family that we haven't ever
gotten before so I'm super pumped about
it far away so I want to start by just
there's there's not a long enough
livestream that we could do to tell you
how grateful I am for for everything
that you've put out I've been following
you since August 23rd 2018 and I have
I've literally consumed everything
you've ever put out unless it requires
me to do reading because like you I
don't read things I've read all of your
books that are on audiobook and I want
to give you a little bit of context on
on Who I am before I go into my
questions so I'm a 31 year old
stay-at-home stepdad and on the side
I've got this dream to create a
communications machine similar to what
you're doing with Sasha group and in
vaynermedia
so that's my dream to be able to help
small businesses and organizations and
nonprofits and and different things like
that help them to communicate with their
audience in their communities and build
that community so which leads me into
both my questions the first of which is
a lot more practical and then the second
is something that I think I've struggled
with the word that I need to use today
with this with this question I need your
wisdom on okay
my first question is I am a part of the
creative story team for my church and I
see a lot of churches struggle with with
communication with digital content with
building communities online especially
as in and definitely in smaller very
archaic models right and and I think a
lot of that has to do with fear and a
lack of understanding for sure and
leadership just being stuck in old ways
right a hundred percent I totally agree
no and and one model that I follow is
Brady here with protouch tools who
actually uses a lot of yrden logic when
he talks to to churches and helps them
to communicate and what he calls the 167
so there's 168 hours in a week we spend
one of that in church and churches
struggle with the communication in those
167 hours in bits so so that's what my
goal is in being on that creative story
team is helping churches understand the
concept of functioning as a business and
organization without letting go of the
the anchor that they have which is their
message I totally understand so what can
I do there to help by making content by
yourself around video games or other
like looking at your setup appreciate
the mug life and the empathy you know
every time I go garage saleing that's
the show so when I see when I see the
and 64 games in a background I think if
you make content for you okay and then
show its success to the church and
you're like this is what works because
if you try to do it through the church
you're gonna bang your head against the
wall you're gonna get nothing
accomplished you're in the system this
is how I think about education the
education system is is rigid education
is the most important thing in the world
how you're doin can be done different
we've been doing some real [ __ ]
education here for two hours this
morning a hundred percent so I think you
need to prove it through you and then
put it on a silver platter for for
everybody at the church to look at and
say what I really want to do is do it
for the 167 see this is why I I never
text any questions to you because I
always know what your answer is gonna be
cuz you've already answered the question
and every bit as trying to think you've
ever created
what rata G go ahead is to put out all
my best advice for free and then use the
serendipity of non-scalable moments like
this to drive it home to use the energy
exchange right now to be like [ __ ] I'm
gonna you know you know the answer
sometimes it's literally this to be like
yep and and yeah so you're you're 100%
right so that's why I always struggle
with in the sending in questions to you
but I totally agree with that so and so
why aren't you doing it that's leading
me into the second part I am I love it
but I struggle so and I'll preface my
question with this so at the beginning
of this year I started doing what I call
the three sixty six challenge where I
decided to create a piece of content
every single day and it started with
video content I was making videos every
single day I got a camera for Christmas
I got a mic set up that I'm doing my
podcast with so you know it's relatively
it's high quality but it's not the tool
brother you're right you're a hundred
percent right yes feeds coming in really
weird so just give me one second no race
I wonder if it's I don't know that's
right
art Mecca it's just us for some reason
[Music]
are we good
talk to us dust
test test test seven four nine I can
hear you I can hear you
all right everyone you guys are coming
in like really robotic to me got it okay
no worries how about for everybody else
what's going on in the comments looks
good on his end I think it's your guests
yeah you know what that porn plug-in
that you have on your computer right
right right a lot of energy so great you
put I've seen what you do on your work
stuff so it's that you know you may want
to think that plug it out okay okay so
so I started this one this 366 challenge
at the beginning of the year where I
decided to create a piece of content
every single day and focusing on video
in the beginning - first of all work in
myself and it became this this journey
into myself where it was this
transparent journal almost that I was
posting on social media writing down my
deepest innermost fears and thoughts and
it became a journey into myself but at
the same time what I wanted it to do was
help build a portfolio and credibility
and context around what I wanted to do
with my business so so what's the first
dozen I didn't I don't have confidence
in myself the the second part of this is
my real struggle after about 30 years or
20 or 30 days of it I started to think
too much and because you weren't getting
enough views because you got some
negative comments because no I never got
any negative comments every piece of
feedback that I ever got was totally
positive people in my church were coming
up to me you know
I've taken I really tried to do my best
to take your advice and not even look at
that I I know I try not to even look at
the lies and illicit music is it your
overall framework like can you grow up
in environments mean yes I grew up with
a I grew up sexually abused I grew up
physically and mentally and verbally
abused in my home I moved to Mississippi
when I was 11 and brand new school in
sixth grade got beat up every single day
from sixth grade to ninth grade and I
got big enough to where people stopped
messing with me
which I know you can relate with because
somebody get big enough I got
charismatic enough and smart enough and
clever that's right yeah you got big
enough here
exactly but here is where I also I also
for transparency really didn't have that
issue because I had a personality trait
that was so confident so likable that it
didn't make me vulnerable to your point
when you're insecure you know it's a
hundred percent your whole brother all
I'm trying to do for the world is what
my mom did for me absolutely and that's
what I'm trying to do for my kids
because I I grew up in a toxic
environment and yeah I'm trying to do
that for my son you know you're playing
it right you're if you've consumed that
much of my content and you need to
continue to pump complete and utter
positivity into your soul to out balance
the negativity and it's not one for one
that kind of level of abuse as a child
that's like a thousand to every one
minute I can put into you or anything
else that's positive and practical
self-esteem building and believing but
brother you're on your way like like
when I sit here and I've been through a
lot of these rodeos you're very on your
way and I need that Gary I need that
doesn't that's not connected to me that
doesn't mean I I unfortunately love you
but but I definitely am not connected
yet to you but now we are and the
reality is I just I'm good at this and I
just
you're on your way and if you have to
rewatch this clip clip this 14 seconds
and play and I'll repeat every day and
make well I wonder if a lot of my mental
hurdle is the fact that I don't have
enough portfolio or our credibility
because no things that I've ever done
before it's your own insecurity
manifesting it's just um
it's it's your own it's just it's just a
framework it's just where you came from
and your good news you fought because
you had it in you to get out of it and
you're on our way your honor you're on
your real way yeah I know it's just
early in the process my mind is is to
understand that every single day I
repeat to myself ten years ten years ten
years I've been doing this way by the
way and when you get there you're gonna
see ten years again right at 34 I was
like 10 years 10 years now I'm 44 and
guess what I'm saying I'm a [ __ ] hill
at fifty four fifty I was gonna be
[ __ ] crazy yeah bro you're on your
way you're on your way I'm excited to be
connected with you and I know you just
had a conversation with Katie and look I
hate I hate being the the follow-up
person to do something like this but you
know you talk about a lot if there's
something that you want to do to get as
close as you can to the Sun yeah that to
feed off of that energy
I'll save you time if you want to apply
to Andy for my team I'm never against it
it's a real filter you know I'm always
comfortable saying no it's a it's you
know it's a super coveted job it's it's
so it's competitive but it doesn't scare
me to give you that opportunity
you just have to you know you're gonna
have to get through the filter of some
pretty hardcore subjective opinions on
based on the merit of the work that we
can see to make the decision you also
have to move to the New York City area
in an
entry-level capacity financially it's
just a reality the job at the starting
point they're just like anything else
and so if those things match up I'm not
against it 100% how do i what do you
want me to do Dustin will take care of
you gotcha
three minutes meeting I love you back
doesn't get out here thank you so much
for being on the ones and twos
thank you everybody who's watching today
I thought today was remarkably strong
I'm really enjoying it I hope team Gary
B was watching it there's a lot of
Instagram clips and most of all it would
mean the world to me if you went and bid
on the Gary B experience $10 raffle
ticket you can bike you can buy 20 of
them for 100 bucks so 5 bucks a pop
please check it out and here is the full
experience I will see you tomorrow it's
tomorrow 10:00 a.m. I thought it was
9:00 still but tomorrow is 10 a.m.
because one of us is sharp and the other
is not I'm not sure I am giving away the
ultimate garyvee experience how should I
go okay over the last week or so I've
been a gym with my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now but all in
challenge calm please go there we are
challenging some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction
so my auction the ultimate Gary the
experience here we go I'm gonna go off
the top of the head they didn't go on
all in challenge calm to go bid on this
I am giving away okay you get to in the
course of the year you will go garage
sailing with me and film trash-talk also
you can get a workout with me and Mike
pecan tea so I know a lot of you pay
attention to that part of my world also
we're gonna go to Wine Library and do a
$25,000 shopping spree that's right I'm
gonna pay my dad well I'm gonna donate
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000 so $25,000
shopping spree at Wine Library I will
walk through the whole store with you
tell you the war stories and you'll buy
a bunch of a wine beer liquor whatever
you want
we are going to go to a Jets game
together you're gonna tailgate with me I
never do this when I give away Jets
tickets I never let the person sit with
me so you will sit with me during the
Jets game I won't talk to you during the
game I'm completely focused but you'll
get that so the ultimate Jets experience
tailgate full game with me as well also
I'm going to give you one week play at
Vayner media so this is for you and a
plus-one by the way so the two tickets
the will be some plus ones we'll do some
just me and you depending on what is one
full week at vaynermedia getting
consulting and business advice from team
Gary Vee and me for the entire week
hanging out in the pit where the shows
done you're gonna be a guest of my
podcast we're gonna do a wine dinner for
you and seven of your friends at Hunt
fish club in New York City and I'm gonna
fly you all paid plus 1 to 3 of my
keynotes and we'll work on those details
the ultimate Gary the experience I hope
you bid on it I hope you get involved I
hope we raise a lot of money to help
people that need it all so what's so fun
about the o-line challenge is you get to
challenge people to be in it I am gonna
challenge all the banner sports athletes
I expect you in there so that is number
one number two I'm gonna go with ooh you
know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland a super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge calm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all-in challenge please check it
out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all-in challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it